familienreisen das waren für die bad
jannis lange zeit unbeschwerte vergnügen
weder der vater noch sascha oder seine
zwei brüder kümmerten sich um ihre
familiengeschichte das sollte sich 2007
für sacha batthyany damals redaktor bei
der nzz am sonntag schlagartig ändern
und auf einmal runter kollegin vorhin
habe ich anne und schmeißt mir denn die
kritiker auf den tisch und seid was hast
du für familie und ich hatte auch
gelockt und ließ der titel gastgeber in
der hölle starkes wort
und das ist margit thyssen bornemisza
verheiratete band ja nie eine
steinreiche stahl erbin und
leidenschaftlicher jägerin auf ihrem
schloss im österreichischen rechnet
veranstaltet sie 1945 mit ss leuten und
lokalen nazigrößen ein rauschendes fest
zur gleichen zeit kommt es zu einem
unvorstellbaren massaker einige gäste
verlassen die party um 180 jüdische
zwangsarbeiter zu erschießen
danach wird weiter gefeiert
die schlossherrin weiß von verbrechen
lässt es zu und schweigt fortan ihre
zwielichtige rolle ist bei den buggies
nie thema
und ich glaube die dominanz oder die
macht sich so dass das romantik ist
entscheidet worüber matt und überweise
bemüht der journalist arbeitet die
schreckliche geschichte über seine
großtante in einem artikel auf
doch damit nicht genug sascha der als
kind von exil ungarn wohlbehütet in
zürich aufgewachsen ist wird
unvermittelt von einem kollegen gefragt
und was hat das mit dir zu tun um sich
dieser frage zu stellen legte sich bei
einem psychoanalytiker auf die couch und
recherchiert in seinem innern dass die
generation vor ist dass die so viel
quasi fehler moralisch sich falsch
verhalten hand und er bemüht gemacht hat
sie das mir richtig was machen wir dann
wieder mir dann quasi die risiken von
damals und immer wieder die frage welche
verhaltensmuster habe ich von meinen
vorfahren geerbt
sacha batthyany steigt in die tiefen
seiner familiengeschichte und stößt auf
das tagebuch seiner großmutter darin
beschreibt sie sehr persönlich ihr
leiden im krieg auch sie wird damals
zeugin eines nazi verbrechen an juden
auch sie hat die tat nicht verhindert
auch sie hat geschwiegen als familie
wir sind maulwürfe wir uns den zutritt
und ich war den ganzen gewiss niemand
hat vor dem westen wo nicht das klasse
hat mir das sehr sehr nachgang will ich
mich von da an ich glaube ich glaube ich
kann das bei mir eine familie von
maulwürfen diesem verhalten will sascha
auf den grund gehen und einer
merkwürdigen melancholie nachspüren die
auf seiner familie lastet er besorgt
sich die akten seines großvaters der
zehn jahre lang in sibirischen
arbeitslagern inhaftiert war und macht
sich gemeinsam mit seinem vater auf
diese stätten des grauens zu finden
ihre fahrt bis nach sibirien wird zu
einer reise der annäherung zwischen
sascha und seinem vater und zwischen
seinem vater und dem großvater
das gericht hatte das hat er das gefühl
hat etwas berührt
die rice hat mir nummer zeigt wie stark
er jetzt unter dem blitzer hat und unter
dem hit no lied und der kostet ist erst
mal verstanden warum herr vielleicht
können die volle aufmerksamkeit widmen
ich kann einfach eine zu verbinden
gesehen dass das wie so eine art airbag
oder das ist aus mir geworden ist dass
wir mit sascha barth ja nie ist ein
packendes persönliches buch gelungen
und was hat das mit mir zu tun ist
aufwühlend auch darum weil die fragen
des autors zu fragen des lesers werden
wie standhaft sind wir standhaft bin ich
ich schlug mein notizbuch auf lasst das
datum das sich in der flughafenhalle vor
dem abflug oben links auf eine neue
seite geschrieben hatte schiebt den satz
könntest du dass juden verstecken und
darunter die antwort nein